Jon Snow hey youtubers it's Charlie and
I am passing around flyers please send a
raven to Ygritte if you have seen this
boy I'm also here to tell you the
today's plaid day just kidding but today
is jon snow day on my channel so let's
talk about him and what's going to be
happening at the wall in season four
I've almost done all the star children
now I still have bran left to do that'll
be a future video so mild spoiler
warning for everything that's happened
up to now and a game of Thrones for Jon
Snow at the wall and in the north so one
of the reasons why I really like Jon
Snow even though he's not my totally
favorite character on Game of Thrones is
that he really sticks to his guns with a
few notable exceptions one being naked
gingers and the other being White
Walkers but everyone pretty much loses
their whenever they see a white
Walker so I don't blame him for that if
you remember at the end of season 3 Jon
Snow had basically left the wildlings he
basically ran back home he was really on
this espionage mission that kind of got
a little sidetracked
I blame sexy time but hey you would
totally take the bait - he even almost
ran into bran and Hodor but I felt like
bran didn't really address that he was
seeing jon snow through the wolf's eyes
and Jon Snow obviously didn't know they
were up in the tower but once he makes
it back to the Nights Watch and season
four they're gonna be a couple important
things to address one why did he run
away everyone still thinks he's a
traitor too the Lord Commander has been
murdered so obviously there's going to
be a new leadership structure in the
Nights Watch and three the wildlings are
still attacking so just to talk about
the Lord Commander real quick for anyone
who's a big Torchwood fan you can get
really excited because burn gorman
confirmed that he's coming back as that
night watchman who murdered old Craster
and the Lord Commander so he's going to
be in season four but most of season
four for Jon Snow will look a lot like
season one that that is it'll take in
and around the wall he's not going to be
traveling around a lot like he was in
season three with Ygritte speaking of
Ygritte she is coming with the wildlings
and she's either coming to finish their
breakup and get some closure or murder
him in his sleep I kind of think it's
the second one but mostly when I talk to
people about Game of Thrones I tell them
to remember that there are really no
happy endings for anyone
everyone kind of dreams of that happy
ending and you really hope that you'll
see Jon Snow and Ygritte reunited and
they'll run off in a field and
married somewhere and have lots of
babies but no that is not going to
happen that doesn't really happen for
anyone on a game of thrones so that
being said do you think that Jon Snow is
actually going to be responsible for the
death of Ygritte in season 4 I kind of
feel like that's where the story is
going I don't know what they're going to
change from the books but obviously
their relationship was doomed from the
start so let me know what you think
there are a couple other important
things about the wall - obviously
Stannis is headed there with his army I
don't think that they'll make it there
till the end of the season so I don't
think a lot of the bigger action and the
big twist in the story will happen till
season five remember since the wildlings
are coming and Stannis is coming there's
going to be a lot going on at the wall I
don't think that will really escalate
till the end of the season but I do
think that we'll see a battle with the
wildlings before Stannis's army gets
there but for the other characters in
the Nights Watch there's some really
important things going on and the way
that the Nights Watch is changing in the
show
remember they spent all of season one
two and three talking about how they
don't have enough men they're losing
people to the White Walkers everyone
keeps dying they have no food and no one
knows how to fight like Sam so they're
in a bit of a tight spot so if they have
trouble repelling the wildling invading
force what are they gonna do when the
White Walkers get there eventually
obviously I don't think there'll be any
white Walker battles until seasons five
six who knows
obviously that's more of a winds of
winter story and that book hasn't even
been written yet that's kind of where
Stannis's army comes in so obviously
since that isn't going to be happening
probably till the end of the season
there isn't going to be a lot of action
with the White Walkers or epic battles
there'll be some smaller battles with
the wildlings because remember when Jon
Snow ran away and ran back to the Nights
Watch they were actually already on
their way to the Nights Watch so he
basically didn't have that far to travel
to make it back in fact I would go so
far as to say that that battle with the
wildlings that raiding party that's on
their way will happen in the first
couple of episodes since george RR
martin is actually riding one of those
first couple of episodes in the season i
would go so far just to say that he
might even be writing Egrets death but
let me know what you think is going to
happen at the wall and what's going to
happen to Jon Snow in season 4 obviously
he's going to be taking much more of a
leadership role as the show gets on I
don't know if that'll totally happened
in season four but now that sandy knows
how to fight the White Walkers I think
he's going to spend the rest of that
season learning about their lore
using John snow to kind of teach the
other nights Watchmen how to defend
themselves so don't be surprised if you
see a lot of talk about dragonglass one
of the really exciting things that
george RR martin is writing right now
that we probably won't get to see in
season 4 though is the lands of always
winter it's basically like Westeros is
North Pole there's actually a lot of
people living up there and I think
that's where a lot of the armies that
the White Walkers are massing so it'll
be really interesting to see that in
future seasons but remember because they
are changing a lot of things we will see
events from the second half of book
three book four maybe even book five
kind of combined into season for my next
preview will actually be for Brienne of
Tarth obviously she does not go to the
wall but she's one of my favorite
characters on Game of Thrones be sure to
subscribe to get that video that will
probably post on Thursday in the
meantime you can click here to check out
my other Game of Thrones season 4 videos
and you can click here to check out my
review for the first episode of Sleepy
Hollow thanks so much for watching high
fives
you